the great thing about football is it's
one of the only professions where you
get to beat the [__] out of someone not
get arrested for it yeah there's not
very many of those sports right yeah and
so that's really fun for me and like
except Memphis maybe I think he can do
it these days but yeah I don't think
it's like as sanctioned yeah probably
not you know it's frowned upon yeah yeah
frown upon but like in the NFL so like I
just get to go out there and I get to
hit people I gotta have fun I mean I'm
playing a kids game dude and getting
paid a lot of money to do it so like I'm
gonna work my tail off but I'm gonna
enjoy it every second that I'm out there
because you only get so many reps
there's only so much tread on the tire
and you got Tom Brady you can play for
20 years maybe 21 and then like you know
but the average you know lifespan is
like three years so I'm going into year
seven I'm doing pretty well for myself
so it's like hey I'm gonna play as long
as I can I'm gonna play at high level as
long as I can but I'm gonna have a great
time every time I'm out there it's a
bigger business now than it was 20 years
ago oh yeah I mean there's significantly
more money in it I mean you just saw
like two quarterbacks just got paid over
100 million dollars with like 70 million
dollars one guy got guaranteed like 83
million dollars that's more than my
entire contract wow that's wild that's
why with Angel Jones right yeah good for
him happy for him I love it when guys
the NFL get paid because it's really
hard to get paid wow and so once like I
love everybody getting paid I do not
care who they is if I think they're a
good player if I think they're a bad
player awesome you got paid good you're
set for life like just don't squander it
please what do you mean when you say
it's hard for guys to get paid well like
you have to the NFL is full of like
every NFL player College you have high
school which is like you have hundreds
of thousands of kids playing High School
right and you just think about like the
number you have millions of kids playing
high school ball you have hundreds of
thousands of people playing uh college
football there's 1500 NFL's players like
just like the percentages is so small
then when you get there like every team
has all Americans in college Heisman
Trophy winners and it's just like you
have to figure out what you do better
than everybody else and how to do like
how to do that for as long as you can
and that's kind of what the NFL is like
surviving NFL is really hard like
there's fantastic players and athletes
out there that should be NFL and aren't
right like that happens all the time
it's like a lot of guys don't take
advantage of that opportunity so it's
hard to get paid you have to have a
right you have to take advantage of that
opportunity what's in front of you are
there any players that come to mind when
you're like man that player it just it
didn't pay it out or they got or there
was a injury that happened or one of my
favorite football players of all time
was Bob Sanders he's a safety for the
Indianapolis Colts he played for Iowa uh
he won defensive MVP one year but like
he just had an assortment of injuries
and he would have been in my he was a
first ballot Hall of Famer and then he
just had all these injuries that he
couldn't stay healthy and then he played
in the pros oh yeah here's what the NFL
MVP for defense like amazing football
player as a safety which is really hard
to do these days and he was incredible
and uh yeah he had like a back injury
had leg injury shoulder injuries because
he hit people so hard that he'd be hurt
and it's just like instead of being a
first battle Hall of Famer like he'll
always be remembered as a really good
football player but like injury kind of
took that away from him and so he could
have gotten paid a lot more money too
probably uh that's what's hard it's like
you have to say healthy you have to be
in the right situation you have to make
a lot of plays and you have to get into
those like one of what are the years you
kind of get paid on what are some of
those levels it's like uh after the most
of the time is like I got paid after
year three okay I was on a four year
rookie deal most of the extensions
happen after three years
or you can after your four-year free
agent is what you're seeing now like
that's where the real money is because
like everyone's bidding on you and
that's where the good stuff is
um but yeah most guys get paid after
three if you're a first round draft pick
like teams have a fifth year right to
you and so those first round draft pick
Matt and I get paid till after year four
um but they already got a you know first
round signing bonus so like they're
doing well for themselves let's see
football is really hard if you don't
love it Like It's really because like
what you put your body through what you
put like the stress levels through like
we put our like I know every like our
professions like when you're out there
you know for like to perform and like
that's how like people watch you and
stuff like that it's like there's a
stress that comes out because you can
make one bad play and like that's the
only thing everybody on Twitter is
yelling at you for and telling you that
you're a piece of [__] and so like
there's a there's a mental stress to it
there's a physical stress to it time
away from your family like I just said
like I I my Nashville's my home I
haven't this is my second day back since
July 24th that's so wow do you think
there are players that would rather get
the ball more than win the game there
are certain players that like you have
to have the mindset that when like when
you get the ball like the more like
it looks [__] scary ah dude it's not
for everybody and it is what it is who
me the ball dude I throw it back nope
honestly yeah hey uh not me not me yeah
no not me dude I do a timeout yeah I
feel like you just toss a lot of bounds
like nah flip coach my bed just drop it
I'm good there might be some guys that
are like Morse like stat hungry maybe
but they're not on our team I've never
really been with a guy that was like
that which has been awesome
um but like and there's there's guys who
have contracts who are like hey if I get
40 catches this season I get a bonus
right like we had a guy who
um we had a guy who he he was a backup
right but he's resigned because his
rookie deal is over and he had an
incentive in there that was if he got
over he had to break his receiving yards
from last year and he only had like 150
receiving yards but he doesn't play a
lot on offense he's a special teams guy
and and by like week five he broke it
and it was amazing because he got like a
multiple hundred thousand dollar bonus
because of it and so like yeah like
there is a selfishness to it because who
doesn't want to get paid an extra 250
000 or something like that whatever it
was I'm not entirely sure but like
that's awesome like good for you and
like I'm encouraging like hey Jimmy
throwing the ball Brock Trey throw that
guy the ball so it's just like
that's pretty fun like so like when it
is like so there's there's selflessness
but there's also a selfishness to it to
an extent right but I'm lucky to be on a
part of a team that hey like Debo's a
superstar he's fantastic and he had a
gamer he had like 20 or he had 20
receiving yards and 20 rushing yards we
won by two touchdowns he's like I don't
care he's like we're winning I have
another option like we have another
opportunity to play next week like it is
what it is and he goes and I'll be right
when I get my opportunity I'll be ready
for it yeah and then you like we had a
playoff game he had a 74 yard touch here
and he had 120 yards receiving a
touchdown player of the game it's just
like we have those guys capable on our
team but we have six of those guys or
seven of those guys they're capable and
then it's just it's fun to be a part of
a team like that I don't get the ball
every play and like I don't want the
ball every play I like I like getting
the ball it's fun to catch the ball it's
fun to Runner like you like running with
a football in open space and not getting
hit is one of the coolest things you can
possibly do as a human being what do you
feel like just driving real fast dude I
have a smile on my face I'm just like
this is like it because it doesn't
happen very often it's hard to get that
open and NFL everyone's such good
athletes but when you're just running
through the space man it doesn't feel
like it's illegal yes like I feel like
I'm a kid who just like I just stole
something I'm just running as fast as I
can and it's it's such a it's such a
thrilling feeling wide receiver think
about that for a sec why do you just
play tight end dude well less money but
I was like I mean you could have already
played another couple years why do you
all get less money
I don't know
let's figure that out you I'll call in
and you're going to figure it out you're
doing more thank you Travis Kelsey this
guy 1300 yards 10 10 touchdowns a year
for like the last seven years basically
but it gets more ball thrown over than
you sure but my point is is that
if he was a wide receiver his contract
he'd be the 26th highest paid wide
receiver in the NFL does that make sense
no no he should probably be top five
so that's that I don't know he should
probably be making if like there's water
she was out there making over 25 million
dollars
that don't get his stats like why would
he not get paid more yeah right I mean
like I was I think I was 30 NFL in
touchdowns this year and yeah I mean
there's 20 receivers that make more
money than me
no yeah no I'm happy for them I'm happy
no it's nothing against them it's just
like that's the title market like our
franchise tag is like 10 million dollars
which is like if a team doesn't like
um Evan Ingram tied in for the Jackson
he was franchise tag which means like
they don't want to do a new deal yet but
they're going to give you a one-year
deal and it's based on the average of
like the top couple contracts of your
position it's like his was 10 million
dollars and then the quarterback
franchise tag is 30 million dollars for
that one season
and I get the quarterback is the most
right that's the most important position
but like wide receiver franchise tag is
I want to say like 20 something but it's
like are they really double the value no
I don't think so especially yeah I don't
think no I don't know especially now
when you get into all these hybrid you
have like taste them Hill you have a
hybrid player that could possibly do it
all yeah sure like and like no not the
thing when you get and
you you have to be great at all those
things for it to be a value of you in a
contract negotiation too right that's a
good point yeah so you have to be great
like if you and if you can just if you
can just do several things but you do
them averagely
I'd rather have like a guy that does
this Great a guy that does this grade
than having a guy that does it both
average
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one